raúl buenas tardes estoy específicamente
en la playa del tarajal en la ciudad
autónoma española de ceuta este ha sido
el escenario durante estos cuatro días
de esta crisis migratoria pero hoy la
situación es mucho más tranquila de lo
que hemos visto en los otros días no hay
inmigrantes en la playa hay que decir
que todo lo contrario lo que se ve en
estos momentos esos grupos sobre todo de
adultos que regresan por su propia
voluntad hacia marruecos o porque son
expulsados de la policía de los casi
9.000 migrantes que entraron en los
últimos días solo quedan sobre todo
menores están retenidos en un polígono
industrial muy cerca de aquí en la
frontera de hecho los edificios que
ustedes ven a mis espaldas los edificios
blancos corresponden a marruecos
entonces aquí están esos menores se les
está sometiendo a tests de kobe 19 y las
organizaciones humanitarias y las ongs
están pidiendo que se les dejen entrar
en españa recordemos que desde noviembre
este país permite las expulsiones en
caliente como se llaman personas que no
tienen los papeles o los documentos para
entrar legalmente a españa son enviados
de regreso inmediatamente pero no los
menores y las mujeres embarazadas ni las
personas mayores' raúl
y entre tanto américa entonces continúa
la atención entre madrid y rabat le
pregunto qué es lo último que se sabe
que han dicho
efectivamente regula hay que decir que
muchas personas creen que esta no es una
crisis inmigratoria sino diplomática
entre españa y marruecos porque
recordemos españa dejó a entrar en su
territorio para que se tratara por kobe
19 el líder del movimiento
independentista del sáhara orilla
occidental que se opone a marruecos que
tiene la soberanía en ese territorio eso
generó la apertura de las fronteras por
parte de marruecos esto fue visto por
mucha gente como una provocación una
respuesta pero hasta ahora el gobierno
española había sido muy muy cauta hay
que decir sin embargo que ayer pedro
sánchez frente a los parlamentarios
españoles dijo que está en una
provocación de marruecos y una falta de
respeto y hoy la ministra de defensa
española margarita robles dijo que la
integridad de españa no es negociable y
que no va a aceptar el chantaje de parte
de marruecos